أوكرانيا تدعي أنها كسبت مزيدًا من الأرض
الليلة بعد اختراق خط
الدفاعات الروسية على الجبهة الجنوبية
أيضًا في الجنوب، أريد أن أعرض لكم
بعض مقاطع الفيديو الجديدة التي لدينا هنا
أمام جندي أوكراني، وهذا
جندي يسقط
طائرة روسية  بصاروخ يُطلق من الكتف،
وهذا ما تنظرون
إليه فعليًا هناك ثم ترون في
لحظة الارتطام أنه يأتي في سياق
إقالة وزير الدفاع الأوكراني رسميًا اليوم، وأنت
تنظر إليه هناك أليكسي ريسنيكوف
كان جزءًا مهمًا من هذه الحرب،
وإقالته الآن في مثل هذا الوقت الحاسم
من الهجوم المضاد هي جزء من تحقيق
فساد واسع النطاق حول هذا الأمر في
المستقبل حيث أن جرس ميليسا الخاص بنا في المقدمة
في روبوتني، هذه قصة ستراها
هنا  في البداية،
يرفرف العلم الآن فوق ما تبقى من
الروبوتات، ويقول القادة الأوكرانيون إن هذا هو
النصر الأول في
الهجوم المضاد الذي استمر ثلاثة أشهر، وهو مصدر
فخر كبير لرجال اللواء الميكانيكي 47 الذي
لم يتوقع الجنود العثور
عليهم، ولكن  اندفعت مجموعة من الرجال
والنساء المسنات إلى سيارة برادلي الخاصة بهم
قبل أن يبتعدوا بسرعة قدر
الإمكان
للتأكد من عودة
العروض التوضيحية الآلية
[موسيقى] بأمان في
غابة قريبة، حيث تم
تزويد المدنيين بالمياه والهواتف التي تشتد الحاجة إليها عبر
Google
ولكن في اليوم السابع والأربعين  كان لواء روبوتينا
مجرد البداية وقد سقط بعض أبطاله
منذ سقوطهم، أود أن أسأل عن
زملائك في اليوم الذي ذهبت فيه إلى
روبوتنا وأخذت المدنيين إلى الخارج،
وكان هناك فريق آخر لكنهم
قتلواني حيث
لا يزال أجنبي كبير يحملهم  في اتجاه الجنوب على طول
امتداد الطريق الذي أطلقوا عليه اسم
الطريق إلى الجحيم